bières artisanales confit de canard du
périgord jambon de bayonne finement
tranchées
depuis samedi la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet déborde de bonnes odeurs et
donne faim 130 exposants se sont donné
rendez vous pour le grand marché paris
fermé le gros avantage de pari fermier
rambouillet où tous les autres pari
fermier sur la région parisienne c'est
que nous on garantit qu'il n'y a que des
producteurs
aucun revendeur c'est vraiment le paysan
qui transforme et qui commerçait dise
lui-même ses produits qui vient le chef
d'exploitation est obligé d'être
derrière le scande et donc pour pouvoir
parler au mieux de ses produits
l'occasion pour les producteurs de
rencontrer les franciliens et porter les
valeurs de leur savoir faire
on a une reconnaissance en
reconnaissance de
est ce que l'on a une actu manque c'est
à dire pas de nous sommes producteurs
est une occasion unique pour eux de
faire ensemble massa est à et crier haut
et fort voilà ce que nous savons faire
et ce que nous faisons est un gros
bassin quand même de consommation et des
gens qui reconnaissent la qualité de nos
produits donc c'est toujours un plaisir
de venir les rencontrer ce un plaisir
campus paris famille ces grandes
familles donc en plus des rencontres nos
copains qui sont là et ça permet des
clients fidèles au rendez-vous l'édition
de novembre a battu un record de
fréquentation avec 15000 personnes
objectif 20 milles pour ce mois de mai
plus que de bons produits c'est aussi
des rencontres et des conseils que l'on
jungle
saucisson de cochon noir du fromage et
du miel pour le moment il ne reste plus
qu'à passer à table le marché sort
encore ouvert jusqu'au 8 mai prochaine
édition en automne